I am going to play For You video of Fox
News propagandist Sean Hannity's sulking
recognition
that extremist Republican secessionist
election denier Kerry Lake lost
I really took pleasure in Cary Lake
losing you know when it came to someone
like Don balduck losing in New Hampshire
to Maggie Hassan
I was glad because balduck is a disaster
and Hassan is fine and the better choice
was Hassan but I didn't take a deep
visceral pleasure in it
I take a deep visceral pleasure and
carry Lake's loss because she is so
extreme and she was so arrogant in her
being extreme and she was so confident
she was going to win and Trump was so
confident she was going to win and it
really would have been a disaster I also
have friends in Arizona who were really
hoping she would lose so I'm glad all
around
here is Sean Hannity while wrapping up
an interview with Adam Carolla
offhandedly mentioning I don't know I
guess they kind of called it for Katie
Hobbs who by the way shouldn't even have
been running and I'll address that in a
moment too check this out land safely
and be alive you know what I think that
says it all uh Adam Carolla as always we
appreciate you being with us thank you
sir
all right apparently they did have a
drop in Arizona and fox is projecting
that Democratic Secretary of State who
should have recused herself Katie Hobbs
expected governor
of Straight Ahead yeah apparently I
don't know they're telling me something
like the decision desk called the raise
I don't know there was a dump there was
a vote dump she shouldn't even have been
running so this is this is great I
absolutely love this and on the entire
she shouldn't even have been running
thing listen
if you want to seriously talk about when
a secretary of state runs for governor
should there be some kind of special
um circumstance where they have to go
through a certain distancing from how
the election is run because it's
absolutely true
secretaries of state to different
degrees in different states are involved
in the running of the election and if
they are candidates in the very election
they are helping to run you can argue
that's a conflict I am more than willing
to explore that and figure out what sort
of general rules should there be when a
secretary of state is a candidate but
Brian Kemp was Secretary of State in
Georgia when he ran for governor against
Stacey Abrams and none of these
Republicans said a word about it and
when Kemp actually worked to close down
early voting reduce polling places all
of that stuff Kemp was actually doing it
and then Stacey Abram said hey you know
some of this stuff is like a little bit
sketchy because this guy's a candidate
and he's also making these decisions
all of a sudden these very same
Republicans they didn't say well Kemp
shouldn't even be running because he's
Secretary of State they came out and
said Oh Stacy Abrams is an election
denier Stacy Abrams is an election
denier so they are complete and total
Hypocrites complete and total Hypocrites
they are pathetic and I just love I mean
look at look at this face from Hannity
look at this sulking face uh I don't
know they're kind of telling me
something about a vote dump I don't know
they say she won but she shouldn't even
have been a candidate okay uh great
stuff good thing Carrie Lake lost